troisième et dernier jour de vote en
russie pour les élections législatives
ce temps millions d'électeurs sont
appelés aux urnes depuis vendredi pour
renouveler les 450 mandat des députés de
la douma la chambre basse du parlement
les premières estimations sont attendues
dans la soirée selon les derniers
sondages c'est le parti au pouvoir
russie unie qui devrait sortir vainqueur
des élections un scrutin étalé sur trois
jours afin de limiter les risques
épidémiques et ses élections
législatives en russie on en a parlé
tout à l'heure avec antoine au clairon
notre correspondant à moscou
troisième et dernier jour de scrutin
trois jours pour renouveler les 450
sièges de députés de la douma la chambre
basse du parlement alors que plusieurs
chiffres sont d'ores et déjà tombés le
taux de participation en début
d'après-midi s'élève à 42 49 % on a
également appris que 90% des électeurs
qui s'étaient inscrits pour voter en
ligne et bien ont d'ores et déjà
accompli leur devoir de citoyen
plusieurs irrégularités ont toutefois
été signalé mais la commission
électorale a déjà réagi c'est en effet
ce brin cynique amis selon les
informations reçues des commissions
électorales des sujets de la fédération
de russie à l'heure actuelle dans 14
sujets de la fédération de russie il y a
des cas d'invalidation de bulletins dans
un certain nombre de bureaux de vote
non oui au tce jose que saisine faisait
nous suivons cela de très près nous
sommes très exigeants et en cas de
moindre doute nous recommandons à nos
commissions de reconnaître les bulletins
comme nul au total 45 bureaux de vote
ont invalidé
7465 bulletins pour un certain nombre de
raisons tilter cgt liste physicienne
persiste et rationnelle des luthiers ni
par les ados prix de chine en attendant
il reste jusqu'à 20h heure locale pour
pouvoir voter que ce soit dans l'isoloir
ou encore en ligne le scrutin est
organisé bien entendu à travers tout le
territoire russe mais également au
niveau des représentations diplomatiques
à travers le monde entier y compris à
kaboul d'où ne sont pas revenues
quelques images